Up until now, I've been helping out a lot, but I've turned
my back on all of
them.
I
thought I could understand the reason by looking at their faces,
but I felt that I was in danger.
The truth about
who he's in a relationship with, or that girl
wrote bad things about this girl on a backdoor site The pitch-
black truth that's inside everyone Then,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh  It
can't be helped, isn't it? Everyone won't praise me
The truth about the branch incident
Is it
the truth?  It
was a mistake to spit out the response on the internet
.
I chose to do it
or A.
I've always been a respected person, and more than anything else,
I've learned the secret of skiing and making waterfalls rise up.